- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is some examples converting
between liters and milliliters
and just as a reminder,
milli means one-thousandth
so a milliliter is
one-thousandth of a liter,
or another way to think about it,
one liter is 1000 milliliters.
So given that, how many
milliliters would seven liters be?
Pause the video and think about that.
Well if one liter is 1000 milliliters,
then seven liters would
be 7000 milliliters.
And what about 18 liters?
Pause the video and think about it.
Well that would be 18,000 milliliters.
So however many liters you've got
it would be a thousand
times as many milliliters
because each milliliter is
one-thousandth of a liter.
Let's do some more examples.
So here it says blank
milliliters equals 15 liters.
Pause the video again, see
if you can figure this out.
Well remember, every liter
is a thousand milliliters.
So 15 liters would be 15,000 milliliters.
Remember, if you have a smaller unit,
and here you're smaller
by a factor of a thousand,
the number that you would need of it
to have the same as a
large unit would be larger.
So you have a smaller unit,
so you have a larger number here.
Let's do one more example.
Compare using greater than,
less than, or equal to.
So nine liters, how does that
compare to 90 milliliters?
Pause this video and try
to answer it for yourself.
Well how many milliliters is nine liters?
Nine liters is the same
thing as 9,000 milliliters
and 9,000 milliliters is clearly
greater than 90 milliliters.
So what you want to do
in a problem like this
is convert both to milliliters.
9,000 milliliters, that's
what nine liters is,
that's 9,000 milliliters,
that's going to be
greater than 90 milliliters.